dea
今から日本語の講座を行います
名作将軍4位日本の人実に深い興味持ちました
それで自国でしのびについての書籍をたくさん購入 c 格闘技のどうぞにも入りまし
たしかしちゃんとした資格を取るために
達人に習う必要があるので貯金を全部使って来日しましたこれから伊賀流の12になり
忍者の訓練に精を出したいと思います
職業ですか
pou dou dou
んで海外ではこの口説き方が普通だネギんって言うんだ
それよりまだ答えてないんだよねアメリカ人と付き合ったことある
っというか一緒による出をしたことがないんだ
アフリカの権利はお前なんかかわいくねーし多いなあまあやウイスキー
ブーブー sos none 新宿ステーション吸引ゲームザック you do
for her スプー
rs 開ける拙い文レッドステイツオーメンください
ブーブーたらティラーソンちゃーん東北大学有機化学分3年生のウィンと申します
よろしくお願い致し
そうですね jlpt の1球は81年生の冬休みの時に撮りました
満点を取ったのはその夏でしたか内定は素因とデロイトからも頂きましたが最終的に
グーグルに入社することにしました
準州差別ですかいやまぁ経験したことがありますが日本人には悪気はありませんので
あまり気にします
日本に来るきっかけですか
話です桜井さんの大好きですね
あチェーンダーワースターキャスト doodle スターバックス in 月さんま
ちゅあわーてぃすかうんどうー focs あ
hey
あのスイスパンやや強いのは
ブーブー s for app to do
apc れ後半好きですとてもおいしい執拗元気ですターサーシーブリーズ soap
belly ミュートプロフィールディア
チェーンん re not to do ん
今から日本語の講座を行います
me